[Música]
las guerras tradicionales con ejército
en el terreno e ingresando al territorio
de otro estado son cada vez menos
frecuentes las estrategias de
confrontación se han transformado hace
una guerra híbrida y cibernética donde
no es fácil reconocer quién ataca a
quien el libre espacio es un área
particularmente desordenada y no hay
tratados internacionales de control que
puedan limitar los hackeos por parte de
actores respaldados por un estado
hablemos en específico de estas
tensiones que hay entre rusia y
occidente por ucrania moscú ha negado
constantemente su participación en
ciberataques contra kiev aunque en los
últimos días se reportaron afectaciones
a webs gubernamentales ucranianas es que
los hackeos hoy en día son parte
esencial de la rivalidad entre las
grandes potencias incluso en 2016 la
otan incluyó formalmente el ciberespacio
como uno de los escenarios potenciales
de guerra junto a tierra mar y aire los
convencionales y entonces para ello
quiero saludar a nuestro primer invitado
del día ls francisco jg analista en
asuntos de ciberseguridad y director de
defensa de seguridad espacial de la
consultora previa gracias a francisco
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 de pregunto primero
para entender el contexto que tan
complejo es saber desde dónde vienen los
ciberataques
pues tremendamente complejo raúl de
hecho ese es uno de los problemas que en
los que radica precisamente a lo que
usted se estaba refiriendo ahora mismo
que es el problema de la atribución es
decir siempre hay que andar si queremos
ser legal e incluso éticamente correcto
siempre que andarse con mucho cuidado a
la hora de decir que un país es el que
ataca porque en realidad son ciudadanos
bien sean empleados del gobierno de
turno de ese país o militares incluso
pero son ciudadanos de ese país los que
atacan necesito uno se puede poner se
puede llegar incluso a rastrear desde
que edificio ha llegado y se ha hecho y
estoy hablando de un caso real desde qué
edificio ha partido tal o cuál
ciberataque más allá de las fronteras de
ese país pero claro de ahí a decir que
es el gobierno de ese país el que está
detrás ese es todo el problema se ha
llegado a hacer en alguna ocasión
pero verdaderamente ese es el problema
lógicamente el de la atribución
francisco pero digamos que se puede a lo
mejor saber con características es decir
existe un modus operandi donde se pueda
saber que son ciberataques provenientes
de rusia digamos cómo se puede
identificar esto
bueno eso es lo que le estaba comentando
efectivamente las ips se pueden trocear
y se pueden se pueden trazar y se y uno
puede llegar a entrar más allá de la
frontera en este caso rusia por
particularizar efectivamente el asunto
es luego poder decir que ha sido el
gobierno el que ha ordenado tal o cual
el ciberataque en claro en el caso de
rusia en concreto se dice en muchas
ocasiones y se pasa esa esa barrera que
yo le comento pues ética o legal pues
porque es de entender que cuando un
ataque forma parte de una campaña
directamente o cuando ya ha tenido
antecedentes siendo rusia como es
bastante complicado de entender que se
realicen determinadas acciones en el
ciberespacio desde suelo ruso sin
conocimiento o incluso sin el permiso o
bajó directamente las órdenes del
kremlin lógicamente claro sí que es
perfectamente posible llegar a saber que
a partido de rusia en un poco más del
problema puede suponer pues eso sí ha
sido el gobierno ruso el que lo ha
ordenado la semana pasada también la web
del ministerio de defensa de ucrania
estaba fuera de servicio esto pudo haber
sido un ciberataque
segurosseguros que además estamos
hablando de escenarios totalmente
volátiles usted lo comentaba antes
también no solo es el dominio digital
sino que estamos hablando de una zona
pues de las más calientes del mundo
ahora mismo como es la frontera oriental
de ucrania con rusia y seguro que se
pudo ver a un ciberataque aunque bueno
ya saben que hubo fuentes que lo negaron
y demás pero no sería la primera vez y
yendo en concreto al asunto que nos
ocupa no sería la primera vez que de
hecho se responsabiliza al kremlin de
ese tipo de ataques contra naciones que
no considera amigas precisamente como
puede ser en este caso
ahora mismo cráneo claro y en este orden
días entonces francisco le pregunto qué
tanto afectan los ciberataques a la
seguridad de un país con qué finalidad
se realizan estos ciberataques digamos
porque a lo mejor un gobierno dice
quiero sé si voy a atacar a eeuu a
ucrania etcétera
pone varias hay varios objetivos todos
yo creo que se pueden reunir en una
palabra que es desestabilización
básicamente desestabilización de varios
tipos si estamos atacando al sistema
económico financiero los bancos las webs
evidentemente efectivamente
desestabilización financiera si se
centra en ataques como ya ha sucedido
todos estos son ejemplos reales en
medios de comunicación pues
efectivamente
desestabilización en lo que a la
información de la población de la nación
objetivo se refiere y en general
bueno también puede haber asuntos de
corte energético
pero en general el punto es la
desestabilización sin ninguna duda lo
estamos viendo todos los días hecho
claro francisco ahora hablemos de
ejemplos históricos para entender un
poco en 2007 se cree que rusia atacó a
estonia que tan complejo fueron estos
ataques
bueno de hecho fue unos ataques que
se ponen como ejemplo directamente de lo
que fue el primer ciber ataque
coordinado a un país que tuvo de verdad
éxito porque puso en jaque durante
bastante tiempo a estonia estonia era un
país por entonces que se decía modelo en
lo que a digitalización de sus servicios
se refiere y si efectivamente fue uno de
los primeros ejemplos que se citan de
ciberguerra que se quedó en el dominio
digital aunque bueno entonces que dicen
que como estuvo acompañado de protestas
callejeras el asunto es que en abril
efectivamente de 2007 pues el gobierno
estonio de tomó la determinación de
cambiar una estatua básicamente era una
estatua que los años 40 había dirigido
el gobierno soviético de entonces los
soviéticos y a un soldado entonces bueno
pues eso había sensibilidades ya
modernas que lo veían como una especie
de afrenta porque no se veía que el
gobierno perdón que las tropas
soviéticas en la segunda guerra mundial
hubiesen llegado para liberar
el territorio sino para invadirlo y
entonces se deciden mover esa estatua
esto pues como sucede está sucediendo no
cráneo también soliviantar los ánimos de
la población con la parte posición pro
rosado o incluso de lengua rusa y eso
provoca una serie de protestas en las
calles que a la vez van seguidas
efectivamente de una campaña
absolutamente coordinada que echó abajo
por por decirlo de pronto lo que es los
servicios del país francisco que pena
interrumpir es que por fuera mi última
pregunta en nuestra conversación que tan
inminente es que se pueda producir una
guerra entre en una guerra cibernética
digamos en las potencias mundiales
incluso el banco central europeo también
se está preparando a los bancos para un
posible ciberataque posiblemente también
por parte de rusia como sé cómo se puede
manejar esto en frente aquí estamos
bueno quiere decir que las cosas no
están como estaban en estonia en general
en 2007 en cuanto a ciberseguridad se
refiere es decir en cuanto a medidas
para poder contrarrestar esto en general
hablo en occidente todos los países son
distintos pero en general las cosas se
toman muy en serio sabemos que toda
nuestra vida está online de la de los
ciudadanos y también buena parte de los
servicios que empresas y gobiernos
proveen a los ciudadanos que están en el
dominio digital entonces la cosa no es
tampoco tan sencilla no digo que fuese
sencilla en estonia en 2007 pero tampoco
es tan tan sencilla como efectivamente
la otan ya lo tiene y hace ya año un par
de años te lo comentaba antes de 2016
pero exactamente en 37 el general james
stoltenberg hace ya debe hacer un par de
años que comentó que efectivamente el
artículo 5 de la otan podría ser
invocado si se producían ataques a una
nación en el dominio digital en el
ciberespacio también y que las
respuestas de la otan no se tendrían por
que ceñir a el dominio digital es decir
que podría haber respuestas cinéticas a
un ataque a un miembro de la alianza en
caso de que de que se sintiese atacado
que fuese atacado cuán probable es pues
está sucediendo todos los días raúl
realmente puede que sean de menos
intensidad
pero están sucediendo todos los días y
si hay un detalle que me gustaría
comentar y es el siguiente en el caso
concreto que nos ocupa de ucrania es
curioso ver cómo estamos todos
preocupados por efectivamente las
amenazas cibernéticas de unos países a
otros pero en lo que ha puesto en pie de
guerra literalmente vamos a decirlo así
a todo el mundo los aliados de occidente
han sido los movimientos cinéticos de la
frontera de tropas armamento y material
ruso si entonces si efectivamente las
guerras ya no son como en la época de
clausewitz que se dice muy claro e
incluso cambian las bases pero los
componentes genéticos y los materiales y
el tema físico tienen que tener su total
importante